foreign
is going to start off this hour in
Seattle hi Kimberly welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you for having me sure how
can Jayden I help
um okay so my question is I have a 20
year old daughter uh this past year
before I was following your teachings I
assisted her with a down payment of
three percent to purchase a home for
stability reasons uh in Kansas and the
payment is about 40 percent of her
take-home pay she does have a roommate
so you know the amounts are
substantially lower
um but I'm wondering what my financial
obligation is to her moving forward
since I did quite honestly pressure her
into purchasing this house
um
I'm just wondering what what is my
obligation
why did you do that I need to understand
why you put her in such a precarious
situation she's at 40 percent with the
requirement of a roommate
and you said you did it for stability
purposes help me understand
um well without uh without making it a
long drawn out conversation
um she did not have the best upbringing
so she has chosen to uh make some of the
same mistakes that I made and
um she gets herself into situations
where she is living with a boyfriend and
dependent upon them and then when the
situation goes south she ends up
um having to find a new place to live
and is the house in your name or in her
name no the house isn't it's in her name
completely and so she is her roommate
you know based on Dave's teaching he is
a roommate
um is her boyfriend
so on some of the uh on some of the
other life decisions
Have you shared with her hey I did this
thing
and I I was wrong and I shouldn't have I
goofed up and I wish you for your sake I
wish you wouldn't do it Have you shared
that kind of stuff with her about those
life decisions
then this is another one
okay your only obligation is to
apologize
I didn't I I did this out of a good
heart I was trying to get you into a
stable housing situation so you didn't
make some of these other relational
mistakes so I did it with good
motivation but since you did that I have
learned some things that I didn't know
at the time that's made me realize that
it's put you in a different kind of
instability and I'm sorry for that and I
you know I'll coach you I'll walk with
you and uh if we don't if you don't see
your income come up pretty dramatically
in the next couple of years to where
that uh percentage comes down uh then
you probably ought to sell it that's
what I would tell her if she was my kid
okay but you don't have any financial
obligation
okay
just tell her if you can't if you can't
get your income up I may have helped you
make a mistake I'm sorry for that you
may need to undo the mistake by selling
the house if you can't get your income
up that's what I would tell her if she
was mine
okay but you you're signing on and I've
got to help her pay payments because I
feel guilty because I screwed up no no
she's a grown woman she's 20 years old
she has the legal right to purchase a
house she had the legal right to tell
you to uh take a flying flop and she
didn't
okay she has these legal rights and so
she's an adult she gets to make the call
and
uh granted you had undue influence
probably I I get what you're saying and
I don't disagree with you but that does
not make you financially legally morally
ethically obligated but I would go to
her and say hey I've learned some stuff
like I did about other things I talked
to you about and this is the money part
and you know here's what we're doing
what does she do for a living
he works at a bank doing what
um I am not exactly sure what her title
is do you have any idea what her career
track looks like is she going to see
some pretty good income increases is she
in a training program where income's
going to go way up later
um I hope so and um I'm not kidding you
have no clue what's your relationship
like with your daughter do you are you
guys on a speaking regular basis does
she do you get the feeling that she
trusts you and that she values your
input or are things
frayed
no we're very close and she definitely
trusts my input yeah I would just say
listen unless you see your income coming
up I may have led you into an unstable
situation when I was trying to help you
stabilize I goofed so I just want to put
you on a warning that you might this
might not be Nirvana that you signed up
for and you you know if you don't get
your income up you may want to look at
selling this within a year or two you
know it's not the end of the world short
term she can make it uh and with a
roommate she can certainly make it but
um you know she went from being
dependent on her boyfriend now she's
dependent on a roommate so we're always
you know because we're over strapped and
that's what we're doing so you've got a
good heart Kimberly you're a good mom
you were trying you're doing your best
we're all trying to figure this thing
out as we go and um uh and then for the
rest of you out there to Jade's Point
um
sometimes what the culture whatever
people are saying
whatever they said and I heard are
saying about money they're all broke
so whatever they're saying don't do it
and in a sense that's what Kimberly did
she said everybody says her life will be
better if she gets a house
everybody says no matter what you spend
if you get a four-year degree even if
it's in left-handed puppetry or German
polka history even if you get a useless
freaking degree and you go two hundred
thousand dollars in debt it's all going
to be okay because education is
important everybody says everybody is
stupid
Show everybody's broke yeah whatever the
culture is telling you normal sucks you
do not want to be normal do not be
conformed to this world and that's in a
sense Kimberly was trying to do the
right thing and no not innocent she was
trying to do the right thing but she the
the the pattern or the uh template she
was using was that of a broke culture
that's right owning a home is always
good for you
and owning a home is not good for you
when you're broke
that's why they call them brokers
you get broker and broker